hey 42 here the world is full of secret
underground societies that operate in
the shadows and meet behind closed doors
in windowless rooms some believe these
societies are secretly running the world
let's find out more about the
organizations that don't want to be
found out
the Skull and Bones order is a senior
secret society at Yale University in
Connecticut its members are called
Bonesmen it was founded in 1832 and is
still running today membership is
restricted to only a few highly elite
individuals members meet every Thursday
and Sunday of each week in a building
called the tomb both of the Bush
President were members of the Skull and
Bones Society while studying its Yale
and the majority of its other members
have gone on to achieve great fame and
fortune numerous conspiracy theories
surround the group some believe they are
the American branch of the infamous
Illuminati but the most popular theory
is that the CIA was formed by members
from the Skull and Bones Society and
that they still control the CIA to this
day next up is the Bilderberg Group the
name for a secretive annual conference
of approximately a hundred and fifty
highly influential individuals
membership is strictly by invitation
only consisting of mostly prime
ministers and presidents from the most
powerful countries in Europe and North
America these make up two-thirds of the
club's membership the other third of the
members are said to be major
international bankers and media moguls
the court meets every year at a
secretive location around Europe and
America what the group discusses is kept
top secret but it is believed that they
discuss how countries and major
organizations can better work together
to improve their economics and the
Fenne systems in other words they
discuss how to run the world more
economically under fish inflate because
of the secrecy of the grief and the high
profile of its members the Bilderberg
Group is surrounded by controversy and
conspiracy theories the Freemasonry
organization is a deeply historic
fraternity that can trace its roots back
to stone masons in the early 17th
century Freemasons meet regularly and
are generally focused on improving the
lives of their members and community
they also give heavily to charity
despite this they are highly secretive
being such a historic organization
freemasons perform various rituals
during their meetings and use secret
signs and handshakes to recognize fellow
Masons and gain entry to meetings
conspiracy theorists often link
Freemasons to groups such as the
Illuminati believing that they are a
contributing force to the New World
Order next up is the Knights Templar the
Knights Templar were a Military Order
set up by the Roman Catholic Church
around 1129 the group had a highly
secretive initiation ceremony commonly
adorned and distinctive white Mantle's
with a red cross they were the
wealthiest and most skilled fighters of
all the Christian Crusades
there were also noncombatant members of
the Knights Templar who were in charge
of managing a large economic
infrastructure throughout Christendom
the organization created financial
techniques that were the earliest forms
of banking they also built many military
fortifications across Europe and the
Holy Land one of the most famous legends
is that the illustrious Holy Grail and
possibly the Ark of the Covenant were
discovered by the Knights Templar at
Temple Mount the Hashshashin were a
mysterious group of Muslim assassins
that operated in the Middle East during
the 13th century the group was made up
of Shia Muslims who banded together in
order to create a new utopian
state the group heavily used guerilla
tactics in battles against their enemies
such as espionage sabotage and political
assassination they worked by placing
highly-trained moles inside enemy
stronghold and instructed them to only
attack when the time was right it is
reported that enemy leaders would awake
in the morning to find a Hashshashin
dagger lying on their pillow along with
a note saying you are in our grip the
group became legendary contract killers
even performing jobs for high-profile
individuals such as King Richard the
Lionheart it is believed that the word
Hashem is where the modern word assassin
comes from founded in 1957 the cadaver
Society is a secret society based at
Washington and Lee University in
Lexington Virginia the group is
extremely secretive and its membership
and organizational structures are
unknown the society must be very wealthy
because it has made numerous substantial
donations to the university itself over
the years it is rumored that the cadaver
Society has a network of underground
passageways spanning throughout the
entire university campus it is believed
that the Society uses these tunnels to
travel around the campus undetected
there are peculiar small locked doors
all across the campus that seems to
support this theory such as this one in
the laybourne library some believe the
cadaver Society to be a branch of the
Illuminati next up is the Hermetic order
of the Golden Dawn not the catchiest
name for a secret society they were
devoted to the study and practice of the
occult metaphysics and paranormal
activity and everything considered
magical during the 19th and 20th
centuries the order has been one of the
single biggest influences on 20th
century Western occultism such as wicker
another infamous occultist organization
is the auto Templi Orientis it is an
international fraternal and religious
Society founded in the beginning of the
20th century it is dedicated to the law
of fell over which was developed by the
well-known British writer and occultist
Aleister Crowley who went by the
nickname of great beast the organisation
uses highly stylized rituals for
initiation during their meetings many
Egyptian gods are invoked as well as the
devil they are known for sometimes
performing their rituals completely
naked the Ordo Templi Orientis claims to
have over 3,000 members worldwide
Rosicrucianism is a philosophical secret
society founded in late medieval Germany
around the 16th century
Rosicrucians opposed Roman Catholicism
rejecting the idea of dogma and instead
relying on evidence and experience to
form conclusions it is believed that the
Rosicrucians were one of the biggest
influences on the creation of
Freemasonry it is also rumored that
isaac newton was a member and finally of
course is the illuminati originally
known as the bavarian illuminati they
are a secretive group formed during the
Age of Enlightenment on May the 1st 1776
the Illuminati's original goals were to
oppose and put an end to superstition
and religious influence over public life
they encouraged people to think for
themselves instead of doing what the
state and their religion tells them to
do the Illuminati is made up of mostly
atheists naturally the Roman Catholic
Church didn't take too kindly to the
formation of such a group so in 1784 the
Illuminati along with Freemasonry were
outlawed by the Bavarian leader Charles
Theodore with the encouragement of
roman catholic church however this
didn't perturb the Illuminati they
continued their meetings and pushing
their ideologies but now all done in top
secret it is force that's operating in
the shadows and from behind closed doors
the Illuminati were responsible for the
French Revolution it is also for by
scholars that the Illuminati collapsed
entirely in the late 1700s but some
believe they are still very active to
this day and are secretly operating and
managing the major governments of the
world and that they seek to create a
one-world government based on humanist
and atheist principles thanks for the
view subscribe for more thoughty2
you